Hey traders, it's Mike, and in this
video, we're talking about the order
flow exhaustion entry method. Now,
you know, one of the questions that I
get is, you know, hey, do I just sell
every exhaustion print? Meaning, you
know, you got a seven here, a four here,
uh you know, an eight coming in right
here, a one here. What am I supposed to
do? Just sell this one, this one, this
one, this one? No. The Just because you
have an exhaustion print, that's only
one part of the puzzle, right? You got
You got to start adding in other aspects
of order flow to it. Now, the exhaustion
print, in theory, is
a reversal signal, right? Because why?
It's because, you know, when you see
exhaustion, that that's telling you,
um you know, the last buyer has bought
in an uptrend or the last seller has
sold in a downtrend. But, again, that's
only one piece of the puzzle, because if
the last buyer has bought in an uptrend,
what do you expect the market to do? You
expect the market to start dropping.
And in this case, you know, you have
your exhaustion print, but the market
went up. Now, you've got your exhaustion
print up here. Now, the market went
down. Okay? So, obviously, this one here
is going to be, you know, the the more
powerful one than this one earlier. So,
how can you tell the difference? Right?
I'll talk about these other ones a a
little bit later is, you know, look at
the actual order flow in the bar. Okay,
it's good that you got a red bar, right?
This is also got a red bar. All right,
but what's the difference, right? This
one's got two selling imbalances. This
one's got uh six selling imbalances.
Okay? What else? Well, here you got one
buying imbalance up here. You've got one
buying imbalance. But, what else? Well,
obviously, the main thing is what
happens next in the next bar.
Is it trading lower, right? You want to
see the price action come in.
The next bar immediately trades lower,
takes out the low of the bar with
exhaustion. In this bar right here, it
didn't do it, right? It went inside and
closed up at the top of the bar, nice
green candle. So, if you're looking for
exhaustion, right? You're looking for
the last buyer has bought here. Oh, they
bought seven. Now, you're going to be
looking for what? Gravity to take over
and the market to go down. If the market
trades inside of the previous bar,
that's a terrible sign. Up here, you've
got the sign of price being exhausted.
It just traded four.
And what happened? Price starts going
lower. That's what you want to see. I
mean, it's a simple concept, right?
Just because you have something happen
in the order flow doesn't necessarily
mean that it's an automatic buy or an
automatic sell. You know, the market has
to react to it also. And again,
remember, with exhaustion, when buyers
are done buying, selling should come in,
right? Not
just go sideways on you like it does
here with this inside bar and then
aggressive buying come in. You can see
the buying imbalance right here. What
you want to start to see is what? Is
aggressive selling coming in. Next bar
has got a selling imbalance. Next bar
has got negative delta. Over here, this
green candle has got what? It's got
positive delta, right? That's not what
you want to see if you're looking for
this market to start to come off. And
people say, "Well, then what's the point
of trading exhaustion, Prince?" Well,
you know, in this case, the market had
already been rallying. Okay, aggressive
buyers maybe taking a pause here, right?
But once aggressive buyers take a pause
here, you got to start looking for what?
Aggressive sellers to come in and that's
going to show up in the delta. Here, you
got the positive delta. Here, you've got
the negative delta.
Okay? Now, there's a few other things in
this other bar as well.
Right? It's got this these thin prints
in here, zero and two. So, you know that
this market is coming off pretty quick
inside of this bar itself with these
selling imbalances because there's very
little counter trade. There's zero,
there's two, there's 15 and then there's
another two, 14, 16. So, you know,
aggressive sellers just come in and
whacked it down and turned it off here
for 150 contracts. So, I'm not surprised
to see this market to start to sell off.
Now,
the market started to sell off and then
it went sideways before it dropped about
10 points, you know, so you had a great
entry in here around the 74 72. Um it
just sort of paused and then dropped
down a few minutes later down, you know,
below 74 60.
So, that's a nice What is that? Um
12 to 14 points. 74 58 would be 14
points. You know, what's your risk on
the trade? If you're getting short
somewhere in here, you know, your stop
is just right here. This one gave you no
entry, right? Even though you just have
the exhaustion print. Right? That
doesn't
signal an automatic short. We don't even
trade below here. Okay? So, there's no
trade coming in here. Now, if you're
short and you're in this trade, right?
You got a two here, an exhaustion print,
and eight. Um even here you've got a
one.
But these are not swing highs, okay?
This is a market that's going sideways,
okay? So, I'm not really looking for an
exhaustion print in a market that's
going sideways.
Now, the other important thing to note,
also in this bar itself at this swing
high,
we have bearish
value area absorption, right? That's
this red point of control, right? I I
made a video the other day on my A+
order flow value area absorption setup,
right? And you got you got a swing high
up here with bearish absorption or
basically distribution. You know, that's
that's added to the the fact that you
got that exhaustion print, it's a nice
short opportunity.
And you know, this is what? 1:09 p.m. 10
minutes later, we're trading 14 points
lower.
Very easy trade to take.
Okay? So, that's the difference, right?
Just because you have an exhaustion
print, doesn't mean it's an automatic
short. All right? Read in what is
actually happening in the market. All
right? Because, you know, sometimes
traders say, "Hey, can I just automate?
I just want to get short on every single
exhaustion print." No, that that's not
the point of exhaustion, right? One, you
got to be having a move, okay? So, we
had a move. And then, you want to start
seeing the aggressive selling coming in
because if the last buyer has bought,
yeah, the market should just naturally
start to trade a little bit lower.
Okay?
But, if it comes right back with
positive delta, that's not a good sign,
right? It's not a sign of aggressive
selling being in control. Here, you
could even see the bar right afterwards,
it's got a nice strong negative delta.
And, you know, the other thing to add to
it, the other difference that took place
over these bars as opposed to these
bars,
okay? As we were going up here, right?
Nice strong positive delta getting
stronger, 276, 538. Little bit of profit
taking came in on this bar, right? With
the small negative delta. But, here,
as we keep going up,
okay? We had the strong delta here, 401.
Then, we had smaller delta of just
um 81. Okay? On the swing high, a small
delta of minus 31.
Then, obviously, minus six. And then,
the strong aggressive selling showed up
with minus 400. Okay? So, you're sort of
you can see the aggressive selling
starting to come in here. It has flipped
in a sense from strong aggressive buying
here to strong aggressive selling right
in here as the market is doing what? As
it's starting to turn from a move up to
a move down.
All right? So, hopefully, that will
clear up some of the questions that I
was I was getting about the exhaustion
prints. Do we Do we just trade every
single one? No. Put it in context of the
market. Put it in context of the other
order flow that's taking place. More
importantly, put it in context of what
the market's doing. All right? If you
look if it's a reversal signal, the
market's got to start reversing. If the
market's not reversing, meaning taking
out the low
of the most recent bar, then it's
probably not going to happen. I mean, it
could, you know, eventually I mean, some
traders will say, "Well, yeah, you got
this move here, but up here on this bar
right up here
at the apex, this is really the stronger
signal to take than this one. There's
There's really no reason to get short
off of this bar right here. No reason.
Big X. This one, yes. Right? All the
signs were
there on this high to get short, right?
And again, just because you got an
exhaustion print here, exhaustion print
here, it doesn't automatically mean it's
an automatic short. Right? It's nice to
see it when you're this bar is coming
in. But here, I mean, you could argue
that they got a bullish exhaustion print
here. So, you got a bearish, bullish,
bearish. You want it's a reversal
signal. So, you got to have a move that
you're reversing, not in the sideways
market like this.
Okay?
So, I hope that clears up some of your
questions. Thanks, guys, and I'll see
you guys on another video.